welcome back everybody to a stream
podcast season do work like that
that's enthusiasm out there so good to
be back everybody I hope you had an
excellent New Year's Christmas
everything that happened everything hope
it's great here with our the boys I
think that's the best way say we are
here with Eric from comment etiquette
hello we air also here with Jack up
Jack's the film's Cheers Jack's not your
real name
jack is not my real name it's John how
did is Jack a name or is it just
completely an alias so Jack is just a
sumed nickname of John so like you know
really John F Kennedy he was he people
knew him as Jack would make that much
sense to me because it's like you know
it's not it's not like a nickname like
you're not shortening anything or like
it's just the letter the first letter is
the same it doesn't make any logical
sense but hey John oh you have to name
John my legal items John Douglas but
nobody calls me John you go Mike I go by
Jack my own and mother calls me Joe well
god bless ya Wow who is John Simek [ __ ]
him
today's episode is sponsored by hims
Boleyn branch equip and lift next week
before we get too deep into this we have
got mark Marcus Brownlee they K and K
beat HD you guys know him o short is the
best I love him very very excited all
right he's so hot right now he's one of
the most prolific tech reviewers on
YouTube a huge fan leave questions for
him on the subreddit an unusual time
that episode will be airing Wednesday
the 24th at 7 p.m. PST a little late for
all you night owls as is tradition with
these fine guys let's get drunk end and
work on ruining my career
anyways everybody hope you all have you
know I feel like we're one of the same
person wherever it is that I am you're
included right so Eric brought this by
the way and he said it was quite bad was
a matter strange I never said it was
good okay for the record yeah so solid
start it's definitely a cringe pretty
hard hmm
that's a sipper that it's not a
chocolate zipper it's perfume yeah I'll
say it's bad gross really I don't mind
it
that's some cold weather but it comes
from Norway that's when it's like dark
for a week straight and you're like it
just kills me Oh like one of those real
northern uh yeah absolutely it's gotta
sting that's on the bottle I think so
how you guys been talk to me what have
you been up to Jack oh boy
so I had a nice little Christmas New
Year's holiday break back in the East
Coast just kind of ping ponged
everywhere from Maryland New Jersey to
Pennsylvania to DC pleasure
traveling like so Oh always for pleasure
yes absolutely yeah it's my king yeah
but yeah just strictly like just a nice
last week and then I had another kind of
like vacation from because normally I'm
always posting videos like always always
always it never stops and it kind of
drives me insane yeah you were very very
active my friends well and it's not a
good thing I need to take a break so I
cut it I had an accidental break where I
went to CES in Vegas last week the baby
yeah it was actually awesome I was there
to meet with brands have meetings blah
blah blah but it was my first CES show
that I've been to I've never like I've
read on this read about this Expo for a
decade but I never been to one so that
was really cool to go to and originally
I was gonna still like upload three
videos that week I ended up not at all
and it was a really nice break I needed
it like for my sanity like as you guys
know you need to do that everything I
was a total happiness to its total
accident but boy oh boy did I need it so
I was like cherished I do I really
really do that's good so so that was my
break ideas down you keep like good
Google
no I have a I have one of those phones
with the styluses so I think I write I
write everything down I love doing I
might not lose that thing that's what
I've always wondered
it's a notepad it goes in the phone and
I don't lose yeah it beeps if you leave
it happen to me yeah so let me just if I
leave it here let me walk I'm gonna walk
it to you okay let's get it yeah lock
the door when he's done I'm gonna take
the stylus I can leave this here so you
can hear it otherwise won't hear it okay
that's smart
so we'll just sit quietly yeah and wait
for the beep so we'll see you later Dan
get him a new world would you first of
all I want to ask you Eric you didn't
drive here drunk did you yeah driving
drunk I'm not gonna sit here quite an
mmm-hmm Wow that phone is a save the
dead mother Mays lost your stylus man
that really is that was so disappointing
I was so excited to like show off this
cool like lost and found feature and oh
well clearly you are very responsible
phone owner you have carried that around
with you and keep the pen I'm very proud
I wanted to look briefly I wanted to ask
you something jack cuz I was pretty
impressed with with this video here it's
quite long okay yes
thank you very much it was really
excellent as you can tell that's where
all my time with actually yes in your
dragon there you go that's son of a can
you touch me through the process of
putting this together it's actually not
as hard I just I want to make sure that
people could enjoy yeah I'll wait so
putting that together really is not as
complicated or tricky as one would think
so cool I can do it while it's paused
it's neat
right yeah I like that if you're on a
phone you can actually like move it
around to move with you yeah like a
little VR thing all you have to do to do
this is just put all of your videos or
pictures or whatever you gonna do in a
grid right like in kind of a geometric
grid with rows and columns so I so first
I had to figure out like mathematically
cuz I made a couple of more videos than
what is shown here but I had to trim a
few to get an even something squared so
it's like I think it's 13 by 13
so like 13 videos in a row and 13 rows
something like that so then I have to go
and see like the hardest part was just
making this grid so in the 16 by 9 grid
in Premiere you just kind of tediously
better than it was it a task on your
computer it was and originally when I
hit the little export button it was like
booop 400 hours left and I was freaking
out because I you know I wanted this out
now whose I don't have patience so what
I did was I kind of tricked it so I only
exported like two rows at a time and my
computer could handle that in minutes so
like I did the first two rows you know
and then in the next two rows and then
finally I just got like when everything
was exported then I threw all the videos
together on top of each other hanka and
just kind of cropped and my computer's
just handed that handled that fine and
as well I won't you want to congrat I
mean that's just an export setting so
you just make sure like when you export
the video there's a little thing you
click in Premiere that's like VR
enjoy this ya know it's really it's
really nice on the ears
absolutely 170 videos playing at one it
sounds like a nightmare yeah this is
kind of this is the last thing you see
before you die good night yeah I want to
look into the gates of Hell all right
this is kind of thank you very much it's
a really powerful way to review all the
content you it was it was either that or
like a best of 2017 video and I was like
nah screw that I mean how many videos
total where in there 169 nice yeah
congratulation oh we've made like 360 in
our whole career mmm Janome videos you
made on your channel about a thousand
something like wow I finally hit the
thousand one hundred and sixty nine
videos worth of good times yes right and
the monetization amen to that
how are you getting slammed now okay I'm
fine yeah yours are super
family-friendly yeah how about that I
can't complain you're not kidding yeah
no I mean there's still like video I
forgot the blur out in nipple and it
kept getting like you got the monetizing
what I do
oh they kind of nipped that algorithm
good sense then it found it or somebody
reported it like Oh nipple was I
wandering here couple of those now
doesn't even leave alone I was just
reading one somebody was in character as
Bernie Sanders I remember when I used to
give good dick like that that's funny
somebody sent it to me on Twitter
there's a nipple on the side that sucks
that aside I'm fine I was hanging out
with idubbbz once we were when we're
shooting the video I remember I don't
remember what video we're making at the
time but he had uploaded a video and his
and for one frame his nuts were visible
yet forgot he had not blurred it for one
so we rushed home and luckily there is a
there's a thing on YouTube you can now
edit it post problems right you can
which was shocked to me I didn't know
that I was like man you got it you got
to get in there and get that nut out
right I've got a real or that home he
got to it before YouTube did and so oh
thank god
I don't know that there's there may be
images of his nuts floating around to
this day but yeah wouldn't ya if it was
up there for a minute I'm sure somebody
captured it it was like a split second
floating around on 4chan somewhere it's
like a wand Bitcoin on someone's hard
drive there it is I was watching this
video also Jack and I just you might
noticed I am fascinated by Pitbull are
you you I don't I don't underst what's
the deal with pitbull why is he so funny
and also yes why is he so popular yeah
um I don't
okay look I'm gonna try and tackle the
second one but the first one I he's just
he's a meme cuz it's pitbull nobody in
the history of the world has ever been
like man I could really go for some pit
bull right now know was pitbull but
people he's so popular right oh yeah
he's a Multi multi multi-millionaire I
mean he's got a show in Vegas like he's
super popular I think he just makes no I
think he just like there that's my guy
and his photos are just out of this plan
oh he's just she's this guy he's just
choosing just mr. worldwide make a chili
a girl like a million yeah oh you went
through a pitbull phase yeah I just love
it look at his [ __ ] face bro so smug
he is mr. smug to the right of that I
think as a winner I find him to be the
most normal looking here because he's
trying so hard to be like men in black
like bro yeah okay just hear him
one left oh that one too no now that's
my pit bull rumours has it pit bull try
to remove this photo from this that's my
Uncle Fester oh man I think I need to
get down there and find a better photo
but I think I think part of the charm is
that like his music is just kind of like
very easy party music club anthems they
say like there's no message there's no
like greater message it's just like he
has a song literally about fire ball you
know it's just like Eric I don't think
it is what's this most popular song [ __ ]
that's a good question me yo time of our
lives that was the one that you were
enjoying right bro he's got more subs
than all of us so back off hater he
survived oh [ __ ]
10 million we're entering a like Paul
territory with this guy please Jesus
crumbly on Wow why you're the cannibal
jokes Erik come on talk about let's
please you just got played yeah [ __ ]
alright so let's read the lyrics for
this I can't play it obviously because
yeah lawyers will come knockin art yeah
I think it's going down I'm yelling
timber which is re just a really solid
yeah here you know how much of this do
you know do you need to reference this
like I do I actually do that's all I
know I didn't get that can you play a
cover of it I'm gonna get like a bad
MIDI like company don't know the tempo
but let's read this like it's written by
Robert Frost oh it's like that down I'm
yelling timber you better move you
better dance why are you dancing it's
going down like timber wait cuz it's a
club anthem that wasn't no lyrics you
better dance that let's just pretend
this Robert Frost was a tree bout to
fall on the poor guy he's saying dance
he's you're taking the road less
traveled you know you're you have to
dance
thank you I heard that they got the
frost place you think it's going you're
about to die enjoy it let's make a night
you won't remember it'll be the one you
won't forget yeah that's what yes sir
that's clever because it's kind of
turning your expectations on your
had because me now you will not remember
the night but damn it you remember the
pitbull you won't forget the hours got
some real gold in it to the biggity boys
[Laughter]
this was brilliant I thought this was
Robert Frost level but this just
ascended to TS Eliot level oh nice
million views this is huge the bigger
they are the harder they fall
the biggity boy he's a Diggity Dog
that's money that's my new Twitter bio
absolutely he's always wearing a [ __ ]
suit in every picture of pitbull you'll
ever see like post 2004 he's wearing a
suit I have him like Miley Cyrus clothes
off
got him it's working in their bras and
thongs timber timber are still talking
to his boys this biggity boys a Diggity
Dog
timber got him face down booty up timber
that's what you call when a trees
falling okay so apparently that ass is
falling or his dick is either crashing
yeah it's been well it's going down I
like the imagery of a timber along with
twerking on a dick oh the dick is just
something's falling yeah she was the
biggity boys couldn't keep it up logs I
loved it I actually have no reference
for what the song actually sounds like I
know it sounds so weird
where were we face down booty up tariff
that's the way we like it that's the way
we like the what timber that's just lazy
writing that's just they're not even
trying he's liquor than an oil spill she
says she won't but I bet she will timber
it's kind of like the the new like like
Kobe he just has to add it after every
line oh this is powerful so when your
partner round around turned into a dough
sido the genre that's the genre flipping
I love him films do that you know like
from international yeah cute mister your
timbering on at work in the next moment
you're grabbing your partner doing a
dosey doe brilliant writer
go to a pitbull concert so that people
when they're singing the lyrics like go
wait a second what oh they're not
thinking about what they're saying yeah
let's be real
those are the lyrics I mean you can he's
in Vegas right now what are you doing
this weekend like a social experiment
just seeing who's there
yeah it is yeah what is the demographic
I don't know what the age group is the
age group of people here that go to his
show let's type pitbull concert this is
music that falls in a playlist like like
timber comes up on a Spotify playlist
but no one's ever like a goddess t4i
pitbull what Amara plants it's like all
dudes who look just like him don't think
ensued oh my god they're housewives
clean go back real quick I'm sorry I
just noticed 178 best pitbull images
we're in such a pitbull hole right now I
feel like I could talk about this for
hours what I'm not even close to dying
here he's gonna be the next James Bond
you're considering him over Idris Elba
oh yeah I can see that
so he's won some awards you know they
say it's the biggity boys is a Diggity
Dog timber James Bond movie but he's
still pitbull ah no I'm pitbull save
Miami man there's some pit bulls out
there there's some pitbull fans out
there who are not down with this you
know like you know what Ethan I used to
like you and now I'm on subscribe I
thought you were cool and I agreed with
you on everything until the moment you
talk [ __ ] about pitbull and now I'm
coming to your house like bull there's
so much charity around the world find
out how many charities someone donates
him like okay but would you do wrong
yeah why why do you like Bill Gates ya
got bodies John Cena has the world
record for most
Make A Wish Make A Wish you later right
so like most you know what that was
callous I just said that without
thinking yeah it's the funniest thing
I've heard in weeks
but like it makes me wonder if he's
doing all these make her wishes what
Sina hiding yeah I like that approach to
life way more than just being like oh
he's a great guy
being like what are you hiding bro I
have no I have no more dangerous world
record
yeah always suspicious why are you so
insecure it's like when you go to New
York and you go down in the subway and
the guys like hey man don't don't buy
one of those Metro tickets I got one you
should give me a dollar and I'll let you
here I'm like wait no I don't know what
do you have planned even though it's
economically a better deal you're not
gonna it seems like you're doing me a
solid here but some songs off yeah your
intuition is correct on that one there
but anyways pitbulls great he's awesome
he's a he's a musical genius
yeah and he does a lot of great things
though and these guys smile oh my god he
look he may be just a musical genius
that looks really good I want to see the
rest of his teeth before I make any
judgment at least I've only seen these I
want to see the rest of what he's got in
there all right pitbull if you're
listening and I know you are send me a
picture though some team of interest
thing I want to talk about Logan Paul
I mean who obviously everybody's you
know but I wanted to get your guys's hot
take about what's going on there I mean
you guys have any original thoughts on
that I don't think that like I thought
he had some great points you know no so
he wants to he wants to come back he's
ready to come back and that was the that
was the Twitter headline moment whatever
that wouldn't imitation Libre yeah let
me know there was actually a TMZ TMZ
deserves a second chance right he
actually seems this is really this is
good content you guys don't don't snuff
yet okay yeah I like serious ting stuff
I liked your post about TMZ moment oh I
haven't seen the video I don't know
those videos great by the way and he's
he's in grief right now about it still
walking around me for what well his
career
oh he's in full pink maverick gear yeah
like bro where swear something else for
now that's the grieving color of choice
absolutely know the port while I feel
really bad the poor guy has to rely on
his on his merch sales right now because
he can't upload videos on YouTube at the
moment cuz he's in grieving Horgan oh
and you can only rely on his you know
eight figure merch sales I feel really
bad for the kid I've heard that he makes
I mean this is all rumor but I believe
three million a month emerge god bless
that sounds about right
honestly yeah that's I'd be surprised if
not more that's what by the way shake
your dick playboy like I'm not hating
I'm just more interested yeah I mean
yeah they're doing something right from
a business model that's true and that's
about it
make just as much his as him and don't
have the nearly the amount of notoriety
that comes with that's true I'm just
[ __ ] [ __ ] that dude you suck man
entertainers or just yeah like well like
even YouTube like I don't know
PewDiePie probably oh clearly up there
you know but he's not [ __ ] he's not
wearing it on his still is his [ __ ] out
of like is his room right
not that I'm blowing PewDiePie over here
drinking this Norwegian [ __ ] now it's
giving me a little bit of a Scandinavian
vibe yeah how European um know you like
I definitely agree with what you're
saying like it's one of the things that
rubs me the wrong way about this guy
even before all of the awful Japan [ __ ]
was it and because what the other Paul
too is just their their their attitude
right towards life that they have to
like living you want to live a fuck-boy
lifestyle that's cool I get that but
when you just like scream it and rub it
in other people's faces and like like he
literally in his end-of-the-year recap
video says the price of his mansion
in his video and like I just bought a
six point five million dollar mansion
like why are you it's gonna be used
against them when he tries to sell it
why are you doing that like why are you
saying the like you're we already see
the shot of the mansion behind you
everything they do is about showing
it's a nine message is just I'm rich and
here's how rich I am there's no message
behind selling a lifestyle right he's
telling a life weird thing about people
like Jake and Logan Paul is that on one
hand they they plug their merch merci
merci merci merci
mercilessly right okay but at the same
time they're like look at my Rolex look
at my new car look at my house and also
buy my merch so on one hand
acknowledging that they are made him
rich and then on the same time flaunting
the wealth to whom the word giving him
money it's it's a weird like an economy
I like doing the big money salvia joke
because uh I'm not big money I've ever
actually become a millionaire you got to
stop with nothing big money thing
because I disagree no no I say push it
yeah hard to get away from like an
alleyway what I want so you know I'm
rich from the basement yeah behind the
camera there's like [ __ ] police cars
like blocking off streets Rafic right
camera crane doing behind the scenes
that'd be cool I know it's being an
alleyway I think you should go other
post Malone rope get some braids get
some grit get some Gucci suit yeah just
face tattoos just got like a fate like
if I had one already under the beard and
like during this podcast I just started
shaving it off the reveal of [ __ ]
soir hates a minute you could pull it
off man right no-one else it's just it's
a beard tattoo underneath another ears
the most obnoxious thing I've ever seen
um what at any rate here's Logan and
grieving and his [ __ ] hot pink
maverick mark I'm good man how are you
how are you feeling
you feeling sighs so you feeling all
right do you think you deserve a second
chance bro you think you deserve a
second you somo pieces so uh sorry I
couldn't hear you
here's the deal I don't think I don't
think it's right to like I'm not gonna
judge him in this video because he's
being accosted by TMZ sure and like he
looks kind of weird and shifty I would
be weird and shifting in that scenario
sure people were like you know like he's
trying to is he at the airport it looks
like he's trying to get from point A to
B like I'm not defending you know I
strongly disagree with pretty much
everything he stands for but I don't
think like the video yeah the video says
well he talks he does make a statement
he does but like but who's asking the
question it's TMZ they approached him
with the question so of course it
weren't for this video he probably
wouldn't even make a statement about
reserving a second choice of course so
that's I'm saying no it's very with a
grain of salt
it's very for this whole thing yeah
that's all with that being said [ __ ]
this guy look nice guy does everyone
have a second chance okay
probably not I'm not ever surely not
everybody cared about these parents to
lock their kids up I don't think they
deserve I think that point I think this
kid sucked maybe they were know like he
know what he was doing yeah I want to
get into that a little bit later okay
okay
I can guarantee those kids are watching
this so we're fine yeah yeah we're good
I don't think they know what computers
are they're learn it's like a yell
situation they were raised by wolves
parent or the movie now what now yeah
Jodie Foster they find like a feral
child country story somewhat it like
they it was a similar stages but they
took a lot of liberties check out now I
know this podcast brought to you by
Tamela
no
listen let's take a quick quick break
we'll be back there's so much to talk
about are you freaking kidding me if
you're thinking about leaving why why
super timber there's bats you can I'm
gonna tell you thing about how I got
read pilled oh oh wow did you boot that
read fill or was it or it's a big pill
dude let me just say it's a big pill all
right tell me that all right so guys
stay tuned we'll be right back with all
kinds of booths don't go anywhere
thank you to hims for sponsoring this
episode of the H Street podcast this is
not a problem
that I am fortunate to say I don't
struggle with it but I have friends who
suffer from baldness and I know from
them that it's not easy okay it's tough
out there to wake up your hairline is
receding and you wonder why has life
dealt me this hand I personally think it
looks distinguished I think if your
hairlines receding your you look like
Bruce Willis he made that cool you could
be an action hero people with my hair
aren't action heroes so don't feel that
bad but if you do feel bad about it and
you want to do something about it
guess what now you can't okay hymns
my friends hens is what the flip is up
most men are too embarrassed to shy or
to just straight up poor to go to a
doctor and talk to them about hair loss
so here's the deal for hems calm a
one-stop shop for hair loss skin care
sexual wellness what you can fix my
penis - for men medical grade solutions
real doctors offering well-known generic
equivalents - name-brand prescriptions
to help you keep your hair my friends
this is not herbal supplement succulents
Samoas you guys know what I'm talking
about prescription solutions backed by
science this is the real deal okay no
waiting rooms no ahktar awkward doctor
visits save hours by going to four hems
calm you answer a few questions and an
actual doctor will review and prescribe
you the medicine you need to keep that
luscious beautiful Maine on your head
okay
now it goes directly to your dang door
these are good
I talked with the co-founder directly he
seems like a great guy he just wants to
help him guys keep their hair and their
you know dicks heart that's a great
mission statement keep your hair keep
your hair fluffy in your dicks heart
that's the slogan if it's not yet it
will be enough to this okay now order
now this deal is insane for our
listeners you get a free trial of
everything you need to keep your hair
for just five dollars today right now
while supplies last
see website for full details this would
cost hundreds if you were to go to a
doctor get the prescription forget about
the time okay by the time you do all
this your hair is completely out you're
bald
alright so go to for hims calm slash h3
that's fo r hims calm slash h3 for him /
h3 guys it's all uphill from here a
downhill not uphill downhill get a house
on a straight line um how is what
how important is here to you it's
important okay I'm very hurt here but
you yeah you can risk it looks good yeah
he's good well alright tone it down I'm
getting jealous
you see I'm jealous of a bald man it's
not that big of a deal
alright moving on wait but we have a
little demonstration oh god I forgot I
completely forgot if you guys want to
know what this product can really do for
you let me introduce you to our producer
he's formally known as Dan and now known
as ace now he's Dennis Willis come on
come on show the people this is what you
will look like after one day of use yeah
it's just been 24 hours less than 24
thing yeah so guys trust me with four
hams calm /h three all your dreams will
come true thank you Dan all right and I
don't know what's going on with the
sexual wellness but he's been acting all
right next up thank you to bowl and
branch listen I hate shopping for Linens
I just hate shopping for lens it's so
annoying like going to Macy's and it's
like oh I'm some middle-aged woman who
and whatever you get home and it's [ __ ]
I hate shopping for linen because it's
so important to get a good Linh you know
you know we we're not gonna all agree on
everything but I'll tell you what we can
agree on
we need more sleep getting a good
night's sleep is easier more affordable
than you think you don't need a new
expensive mattress mattress our new
scientific ly advanced NASA pillows like
everyone's trying to sell these days all
you need is to change your sheets that's
why you need to check out Bowl and a
branch everything ball and branch makes
from bedding to blankets has made pure
100 organic cotton which means they
start out supersoft and guess what they
get softer with every wash what you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand dollars they I
don't you know what they wrote that
luxury really ya know the shit's can get
really expensive for bid the spores on
your very expensive but if you get a
good pair it last you forever yeah and
you love it you know and so apparently
there's some sorry sons of [ __ ]
spending a thousand dollars I don't know
who they are
but apparently they're out there but
Boleyn branch sheets are only a couple
hundred bucks for the same quality or
gas you roll in these and you orgasm
take a couple hems take a role in some
bowling brand and you'll be let me tell
you dude life is gonna be go baby
bawling you'll be bawling bald branch
and ball and hair on your balls to
forget about it everyone who tries
Boleyn branch sheets loves them that's
why they have thousands of five-star
reviews and Forbes The Wall Street
Journal fast and fast company are all
talking about Boleyn branch although I
wonder what goop things about Baldrige
say I wonder what I wonder yeah I really
do wonder what Oprah said about it I'll
look into that I think it's great full
disclaimer I haven't received ours yet
but I can't wait and I can't wait to
roll in them and I'm gonna give you guys
a full review of it next time it sounds
amazing even apparently
three u.s. presidents sleep on bowl and
bran sheets they didn't say which ones
though hmm
it's probably the [ __ ] ones because they
would have said their names and they're
the good ones shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund but I
doubt you're gonna want to send it back
because it's bowling branch and you're
gonna be balling in this bowling branch
there's no risk there's no reason to not
give them a try if you need sheets it's
a no-brainer
go to Boland branch comm use promo code
h3 it's a no brainer my friends you get
$50 off your first set and if you don't
like it you send it back it's a no
brainer that's Bo LL and branch comm
promo code h3 get 50 massive clams out
of the price promo code h3 thank you to
that our sponsors guys if you are in the
market for any of those products
consider picking them up and help to
support the show let's get right back
into the news guys welcome back to the
h3 podcast we were talking about Logan
Paul and his fresh pink maverick merch
guys where the flipper way let's go well
we we did watch it well he didn't say
wait did we see everything he said from
what transpired recently everything so
many things by the way this this pink
merch is available at be a booth dotnet
touch-up this video after cuz he looks
like a [ __ ] ghost I don't think so I
think it's just [ __ ] lighting I think
it's like overcast is that yeah that
looks like I gotta agree with like I
feel like [ __ ] when I'm in their report
and I probably look like [ __ ] so okay
fair up listen we have a look at the
airport it's like you're right you're
right Mary this is completely unfair we
have a Logan Paul fan on the line who
wants to defend whom he thinks we've
been considered yeah
so in the spirit of fairness and I just
hearing both sides I want to bring
Jordan here so that he can basically
argue you know
on Logan side so all right Jordan are
you with us what's your name that's okay
my name is Jordan from Ohio about
whether the half years old just heard
and I've been watching your live
telecast here and I think he would say a
lot of slanderous borderline libelous
things about Logan Paul well I don't
think that's slanted why do you think
I've slandered him I did write a blog
post
first of all Jordan that language is not
appropriate how old are you I'm gonna
read something that you wrote down about
Logan Paul you said quote ha ha ha laugh
at somebody hey that's cool now I'm
going to explain yourself there sir no I
said well I don't recall where I wrote
that or what I said your personality
your likeness well well Logan did take a
picture with a corpse in the forest
you're aware of that right I hate to
burst your bubble there sir I know all
you coastal elites don't think people
die but but don't you think it's
trivializing suicide to go and use them
as like a prop in a vlog and put them in
the thumbnail and to just kind of use a
body to get views don't you think that's
a little inappropriate do you have any
problem with that
favorite crypto I had tell you something
right now I had I invested heavily I
spoke my parents purses I have two moms
that's okay it's 28 Tina that's okay now
I spoke about their purses and I'll tell
you what I did with that buddy
I immediately went to Jordan I don't
know what the hell you're on man we
gotta get I don't know man are you for
real yeah absolutely sir oh you [ __ ]
really and I'm not tried to I'm not
trying to alert the FBI or any kind of
federal federal federal agency but I
just want to say this mm-hmm I do have
about 25 bitcoins to my name oh and I
will pay I will pay all of that if
somebody can I'm not making a threat not
making a thread skies I think he brought
up some some excellent points he did
people die every day you know and that's
just what do we know and we're just
bicoastal you know frauds it's a smart
kid what nine-year-old for knowing
slanderous 11 and I also count a lot
okay being coastal like hacks but they
also had mentioned that he has two moms
I mean that's pretty progressive yeah
good for him in Ohio nonetheless well I
don't know that kid was a [ __ ] weirdo
no I like them I think you should get
him on the show great points Jordan if
you're out there drop me an email and
we'll know that you're something I'm
just I'm happy Logan did it if I'm
honest because he really jumped on that
cuz who would have thought that filming
a dead body in a suicide forest would
get you in trouble I was about to do
that I wrote a 10 page script about it
and write that video came out and I was
like oh no universe wherever almost just
like it went under the radar and nobody
cared about it because Logan
Jake do a lot of horrible [ __ ] or not
horrible but they're really really
consider it yeah and like all the [ __ ]
he done is Japan vlog that was awful
exactly would have gone completely I
think that was worth checked IIIi agree
the [ __ ] but it's all about it so
easy unicorns tweeted it viral video or
compilation at insane exactly that's a
really really good so in a parallel
universe that almost could have just
gone completely unchecked but something
else would have blown up may have the
the the assassination the fake
assassination that low I didn't know
that until all this Japan [ __ ] happened
exactly
I remember watching that one actually
when it came out really I don't know why
we didn't know it's I was just gonna say
it's like everything they do is so weird
because their friends are kids sounds
like not like he's saying like let's get
[ __ ] like thirteen-year-old kids
they're like eight-year-olds there
there's like a music video that Jake did
a while back with all of his fans and
they're like these little they're like
they're their kids and he's talking
about you know [ __ ] and blah blah
blah and it doesn't make any single your
15 yeah I get that because it's like
what do you think the ages were like a
kid like clicks on a little bit Paul
videos like you know I don't like this
anymore
17 to old for this now I'm should yeah I
think I think there is gonna be a point
and all their lives inevitably where
they're like wait hold on [ __ ] wait [ __ ]
absolutely no there's gonna be a cut-off
point that's nice we may become fans of
ours yeah this guy's not even that funny
hope no I don't know I think he's
actually hilarious but they're so they
have such confidence levels that they
can do anything because all you need in
life is confidence in ignorance and
success is a shirt and cuteness
good-looking quote I do make that up oh
really I was gonna say
we had you for you just drop that yeah
but I've seen it I mean like he's a 22
year old with a comb-over he's 22 yeah I
was 30
that's a nice young girl that's another
twist because it's it's easy to forget
how young they're when I was 22 I was a
[ __ ] idiot no if I had that level of
success at 22 I would be I would be your
mother bodies I filmed when I was 22
salts um when I was 22 luckily I don't
even think you two barely existed so
yeah I didn't have an incentive to like
murder people and film their corpses
right why Jake I can understand that is
young but Logan just doesn't connect to
me in my head with the age of 22 it's
like I cannot affect maybe like fakes is
age oh I heard a conspiracy theory a
really good one from Ian from Smosh
he said Logan is gonna take this time
off to get hair transplants okay time
out is he when you when you briefly
mentioned the comb-over you don't think
he's bald let me show you because I've
never seen this book I thought he had
luscious locks of it okay so here that's
that's truly horrific two-year old man
God and I don't mean to make by the way
go to hims calm for hims calm slushie
unflattering photo it's not helping that
he's along gating his face with the
forehead he's definitely it's okay to
laugh about how he looks because he's so
he's so if you were anyone else I feel
really I wouldn't do this to anyone but
he's pretty terrible so but also he's
like so confident he knows that everyone
wants to [ __ ] him he knows that he's
rich its punching up the guy he's got a
huge ego
look at his hairline right there is a
tad justice that that is the thing that
people shoot for like like you know just
I think with anything I think people
make fun of my looks all the time I
don't get it
yeah I think I'm a pretty dapper young
man oh
I'm 22 you know I'm looking better than
he is
I should make this the thumb so it's a
bit body shape oh no that one's worse
that might be Photoshop that's not nice
oh [ __ ] it serious as a heart attack
see now just embrace it oh this from our
subreddit dead bodies you're gonna go
bald I think that's a fair punishment I
think you should go go shave it all off
kids welcome to the darkness soul ideas
man make all these kids Goths 22 though
can you agreed it so I just what it
feels and sounds and Luke's older yeah
that the the idea of somebody sifting
frame through frame his videos looking
gotcha [ __ ] I think the first
time I heard that he was 22 I was very
surprised and he does seem older like he
just he just looks like an older guy
they say God bless god bless ya enough
about Logan will pop back in yeah we're
gonna come on yeah cheers Cheers got a
bad rap night it's not honestly don't
know what we don't know what yeah you
say you're about what is yeah I don't
know what is made from it kind of tastes
like caraway seeds oh my god what is
this no they don't let's dump this out
let's give it to em so they get in here
Chuck this story I want to lighten it up
a little bit uh-huh you guys probably
heard about the Paris Kyle nice little
guys 12 kids
ages what to 229 yeah yeah and your
[ __ ] chains in their basement
that's a Logan Pole and a half yeah yes
yeah exactly
I'm doing the math on that look everyone
deserves a second can't say anything
without it's like quoting him today I
hate that you know right it's win-win
for him you know like yeah okay watch
the report here yeah so by the way their
alcohol been said it's it's own thing
but it's similar to vodka mmm what oh
you looked it up nice okay similar to
vodka similar TACA TACA so that's my
fighting booze you that's one pizza okay
well you guys don't let me oh actually
I've brought half a Cuban sandwich okay
no not by myself I will not go down
though I'll share my Cubans your own
social eater a social pizza eater I
dress up eating pizza alone is this is
sadder than drinking I've never thought
of my son I don't disagree but I go
you're saying I like leftovers already
fat guy pizza is rock bottom yeah man
you ever have vegan pizza it's the list
not bad thanks ed can you eat the box it
comes in okay seriously don't hate vegan
food no no he says like sex when it's
when it's good it's great and when it's
bad it's still pretty good come on man
it's going down biggity big the doggy
dog that might make any boys are dougie
dog and their twerking like Miley Cyrus
I forgot the horror family it's already
[ __ ] on it depraved guy walked into
like a gas station and the clerk called
911 immediately
that's right I got a guy here it
definitely is 12 kids hostage in his
place named hell trying to find a
picture of the goddamn okay here there
it is there's the early flowering like
oh you know when like they say when you
see his suspicious behavior you need to
call the FBI or whatever yeah the fact
that his barber didn't looks like the
guy who'd seen a tim and eric' sketch
that's a hair that says i have my chance
my kids chained up in a sauna is I can
already tell Jeffrey Tambor is gonna
play him in the lifetime original I was
just thinking that in the way over here
I was like give it 6 months and they'll
be moving about this yeah Jeffrey Tambor
that's a damn dead ringer you put those
family in the 911 towers the day that it
happened and you got yourself a hallmark
like wait a second the basement I'm just
saying you combine all the movie right
it's got all the wits with a laugh track
don't forget the lots of laughter no
what about a screen they should do that
for genius scarier shows oh my god
patent egg people like oh that's you
know what my first thought was though
and it was kind of heartwarming I
thought to myself you know what if this
isn't proof that there's somebody for
everyone I don't know what is
sure
yeah I did well I'm nice what are the
chances that two people could meet in
life and say let's have 12 kids and
torture them and keep them right locked
up shame them up I think it's impossible
it's like nothing I'm saying love is out
there for everybody if you are single
mark my words there is someone for you
this is rule this is an absolute
physical two people were brought
together in love I want to make 12
babies with you and hide him in the
basement by the way I was wondering like
why did you keep having kids if you
clearly hate them that much they said
God God told them man oh those kids are
just down huh like they're gonna there's
gonna be so many crazy interviews with
those kids they had parents seriously
one of the most horrible stories yeah
and and the 29 year old disgusting yeah
these guys should be locked away for
well they're like they're like they can
be charged with life and prison I'm like
what is the other option right that's
that needs to be the only option like
I'm like guys why are you even giving
Warren Buffett the option I have to say
that their crimes were greatly
exaggerated I don't know if that's how
Warren Buffett sums this dude's rock
band producer haircut is really speaking
to me now I'm gonna let him out yeah Tai
Lopez who's most likely to bail these
guys out at nine million dollars maybe
oh yeah can't do it yeah and I just say
to just acknowledge the fact that you
won last time you were here Eric wasn't
the last time but we were here together
shkreli called in after they found out
he's like I just made twenty million
bucks and I'm only gonna get three
months in prison he was bragging about
it since that day the gr note was the
Hillary Clinton threat but I'm almost
certain that the what he said in our
podcast was used to get him against him
in court it has to be I think that him
bragging on our podcast he didn't just
live here what
used as evidence against him to lock him
up he he'd like me to drop just a couple
little morsels on this podcast but he
was just live streaming invited a
reporter up to his apartment he got very
what a lunatic very talky for a guy who
just got found guilty like cocky kind of
yeah down fatal you know it definitely
is a flaw it's got to be some sort of
behavioral thing I don't know for the
guy in a weird way I mean if the guys
got a problem where he just can't stop
[ __ ] with himself in that way like
that definitely Haverhill issues
self-destruct about also extremely
capable yeah it's weird thing what's the
file but he's got he's got works that
get him in trouble a lot like he Ponzi
schemes know you like being like the
evil I like that the attention the light
on him yeah spotlight I think he just
embraced it because he knew there was no
getting away from it you think he knew
who's going down no I think he just knew
people were gonna think he was a
[ __ ] so he was like I'm gonna be no
he tried to use in a way they would get
people on his side he did though it did
work like anytime you make fun of him
it's always one guy he's like oh yeah
he's like five guys yeah but did you
know understood thank you and it's
always like I can't believe you by the
media's Nair know it's like well he's in
prison
guy said he's kind of a jerk he was kind
of a jerk of a jerk like yeah this guy's
a real jerk
this guy's such a dick I want a lock of
his hair urban went before a judge for
the first time since their arrest Monday
pleading not guilty to I love they plead
not guilty
what is that right now how how do you
like we didn't know what that means that
kids had fun
it wasn't there it is yeah that's the
old family of five daddy of five yeah
defense they were in on it so prank he
had a great tweet the other day he was
he and he tried to like all that you saw
the right Franco went in oh oh he did I
didn't see you feel going but like yeah
like talking he was trying to like um
bring himself back into the spotlight
using the whole Logan polythene excuse
me shut the [ __ ] up dude like you're
you're hardly better bro the ink that's
on your career isn't disappearing right
amber this guy's YouTube channel would
be like I was just thinking the store is
a YouTube channel your honor it was a
long time went on for years I hope the
first thing is lawyer said was look
we're gonna get you to a haircut
God told me to get a [ __ ] pretty
bunch mullet ropes these defendants
eventually began using chains and
padlocks to chained up sweet people
victims to their beds
great cut victims work bro they did I
heard this story go this clear so like
what is hey head um they renewed their
vows and had all their family and had
they all had the same haircut
oh they met all their kids there when
they renewed their vows it's a sick
deeply broken mind
Oh minds both together they love each
other so much that they went to Hawaii
brought their whole family to renew
their vows it's that I do it Ben ain't
got the same haircut yeah you guys also
a movie room right that room no just
room just room I didn't like you for
there stuck and then go to room to room
without spoiling it it is about a a kid
who grows up that mean I guess it's
similar enough to this it's a kid who
grows up in like a single room mm-hmm
there's like a lot of very tense scenes
I wish you guys had seen it cuz now I'm
sort of I have room it's great movie it
is yeah Oh fantastic movie I I cried I
cried watching oh alright this sometimes
they get you the room guys if you're
looking for a good cry cry what so is
there a haircut or evolved or what's the
there is a haircut here's a haircut
that's a big sport
bleep that out there we bleed me out
believe everything I say look like a big
happy family you know if those big blurs
on yeah you can't even tell their side
though what if the kids lied yeah yeah
those [ __ ] kid I throw a conspiracy
those kids just did like the ultimate
Parent Trap change themselves they [ __ ]
all over the floor the kid that managed
to escape must be a hero
oh yeah oh I hope so it must have been
so difficult that yeah that's [ __ ]
horrifying
so where is Paris like it's my twin
Riverside California
you're a psycho yeah okay close to home
yeah could be anywhere yeah or Riverside
not surprised yeah not allowed to do
they got like one IHOP one is not
surprised how much my pass I don't know
that we need to keep watching this yeah
but at the same time do we I had no idea
what you guys do we do you think they
feel remorse do you think they feel like
sorry or deaf sorry that there got
caught yeah they pleaded not guilty for
Christ's sake
good point I would look for like like
you know they they finally meet after
the trials over and they're found guilty
and they're sends the life imprisoning
like why the [ __ ] did we do that yeah
yeah we could have just had kids we
could have done it like the nice normal
way yeah we [ __ ] up Martha where we go
wrong you know everyone deserves a
second chance
amen to that oh no I'll slam it I they
were saying that they
like first of all not feeding them they
would have high and tasty tree and oh my
god they would make them sleep during
the day and be up at night okay
the psychology of that is so deep and
dark because like in a way your kids are
you right and so by having kids
specifically to torture them it's like
you're torturing yourself
yeah so something happens from oh my god
what the [ __ ] happened to that guy this
is just are you trying to justify what
the parents did no you're just
interested in like the human mind man
man ever since I got red pill way yeah
it's a giant pill it was a daytime god
yes and it's red and the blue pills a
lot smaller yeah and you just swallow
that one yeah it's different cuz it
makes you kinda sorry so now my beer
it's big I'm getting good game yeah red
pill man Cheryl red cool you guys after
the show please can you red pill heal on
him a red pill you two okay yeah oh
let's take a quick break after the guys
everybody get your red pills out yeah
okay get ready to insert them cuz we are
bad we have so much to talk about
I'm getting drunk I'm ready to say some
racist [ __ ] yeah
whatever it takes to ruin my career as
this tradition with you guys can't
[ __ ] wait I got a whole list of stuff
yeah I had some great bits about
immigration and maybe an idea for a
Rhino death lottery okay all right do it
we do a death lottery but it's Randall
death yeah like the endangered rhinos
were saying some things about like the
the numbers of the Holocaust were
greatly exaggerated their interest in me
backstage I you know I'd love to jump
into that we're gonna get into all that
stuff when we get back from these
messages by the way these are not
endorsed by responses Oh
okay my friends do not go away or you're
nuts because the entertainment is all
[ __ ] see you guys soon
I love quip and thank you to quip for
sponsoring us my friends your mouth is
disgusting don't even pretend like you
brush your teeth enough because you
don't and if you do you don't do a good
enough job here I dare you to do this
blowing your your hand right now
and smell it that's probably what you'll
be doing I don't guess why I use quit
this is the greatest toothbrush ever
made
if Elon Musk made a toothbrush this
would be it he didn't this is he didn't
make this for the record that's just an
analogy I'm using to explain how great
it is here's the deal it's got first of
all the bristles are so gentle and soft
I can't find soft bristles anywhere
Equipe got him first of all second of
all you click it it times it out it
times out your brush so you know exactly
how much you need to brush to get that
perfect brush and it remind you every 30
seconds till about three minutes until
you know that mouth is kissable clean or
at least not puke you know you may be
you won't be kissing one but at least
people will be buccal when they smell
your disgusting breath not disgusting
after clip I loved clip what do you
think about quit vela I like it I think
it looks really cool
evil must made it you didn't but you
know you gave I'm saying here's the deal
you guys I can't recommend this
toothbrush enough and it looks expensive
but it's not it starts at just 25
dollars go to get quick comm /h 3 right
now and you'll get your first refill
pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush ok it's it's it's just a
no-brainer 25 bucks
this is the last toothbrush you're ever
going to need that's your first refill
pack free along with your toothbrush for
25 bucks at get quit comm /h Street
spell GE t qu IP comm /h 3 you're gonna
love it
all right Thank You quip for sponsoring
us God bless you I appreciate you thanks
for listening and finally lift
left the world is changing you don't
have to work for somebody you hate
anymore
assuming all bosses suck they do all
bosses suck even if you love them you're
like yeah you hate you gotta hate your
boss it's just part of the experience of
working for something with lifts you
don't you work for yourself okay
lyft knows their drivers are what keeps
them moving so they do everything they
can to make sure their drivers are happy
it's a simple formula happy drivers mean
happy passengers maybe that's why nine
out of ten lyft drivers get a perfect
five-star rating that's gonna be great
for your confidence give some a ride
they give you five stars because they
love you and all of a sudden you're like
wow uh maybe I'm not such a piece of
[ __ ] after all because everybody loves
me five stars every time you can be so
confident you're gonna be making
hundreds of dollars a week plus tips 100
morning drive more give yourself a raise
lift was a first ride cheer platform
with tipping built right into the app
because again tips shouldn't depend on
your passenger having a crumbled-up bill
in his pocket and guess what you keep a
hundred percent of the tips and they add
up quick drivers have been paid out over
two hundred million dollars since the
feature was first introduced Wow that's
good that's a lot of cheddar and that's
a lot of guac and crack an express pay
lets you get paid almost instantly
instead of waiting weeks for some boss
that you hate to pay you and you got to
chase him down be like hey guy that I
hate can you pay me for my time that
doesn't happen here so join the
ride-sharing company that believes in
treating its people better go to lift ly
ft.com / h3 today and you get $500 new
driver bonus what thats
lyft ly ft.com / h3 lyft calm / h3 my
friends limited time only terms do apply
on that offer so get on it my friends
thank you for for listening thank you to
our gracious sponsors if you're in the
market please fella consider supporting
them and supporting the show with that
being said let's get right back in to
the news
welcome back to the h3 podcast here with
the boys forget your something and one
girl and the ladies have a ton of fun
having some laughs masam gives scope
some laps we're on our best laps it's
yeah sure hey listen we're not gonna we
had toyed with the idea of discussing
maybe Hitler wasn't such a bad guy
we went over it during the break we've
covered a lot of ground and we decided
it probably won't discuss it because
it's so much to talk about
great the podcasts be called good men
evil deeds right hole deeds be done by
good man right semicolon everybody
deserves timber timber you got it good
let's pour some drinks okay yeah so I
mean a little if anyone's interested
there's really specifically you guys I'm
doing a little pineapple strawberry
Lacroix oh you're playing a dangerous
game and mixed flavors of the Lacroix
some mandarin like citrusy vodka oh oh
honey boy mm-hmm
do you go drink yeah all right heard
about Viger third movement yeah like
it's always so divisive the talk about
Trump and I'm not and I'm not here to
[ __ ] on him I just thought that the
girth or movement the name of it was so
funny
they found that I'm going to talk about
anyway doesn't know the reference so
Trump spearheaded the birther movement
the accused Trump of not being born in
the United States recently Trump
underwent a physical exam and people
speculated that they underreported his
weight and also they reported his height
because there's like he's right at the
apparently he's six - and he's right at
the height where he would be morbidly
obese or just some B's than enough more
really absorbance prior so let's go
Chris okay you're right there's a big
difference there why any rate obese okay
yeah obese is such a funny word just
sounds hilarious I wonder if I'm obese
you're not all being obese I'm gonna be
soul
you're the Oh best yeah so anyway they
over reported his height so that he
could get the cutoff for not being obese
and people are calling it the girth er
movement because it's a conspiracy
theory
you know alleging that maybe just maybe
so I wonder what his BMI would be then
given the the weight and height ratio I
mean obviously that's why they did that
wrong but but apparently the President
himself is going to be calling in to
discuss this issue with us a little bit
later [ __ ] I swear to god it's weird
but this shows getting kind of a into a
big deal hey congrats on getting on that
level guys the president s dude it's a
real thing we ID am with him sometimes
Trump is telling me he's like Fox and
Friends seriously we can't say to him
okay okay oh that's cool don't like
threaten his life oh well but the Secret
Service is not down I'll bet you know he
gets a lot of crap but I'll bet if you
just like sit down with him have a few
diet cokes right he's a really nice guy
I hear that's that's a yes here no oh my
god everybody well the President of the
United States President Trump is here on
the phone with us right now to discuss
the girth remove it hello present mr.
president okay everybody has four words
everybody
this Jack Douglas guys he's totally
bearing a watch on his wrist
okay doesn't everything that he knows
his name
stay with it his name is John right John
everybody comes free on that is correct
this guy is a total disaster okay but
nobody will talk about it and that he's
here are you fat mr. president what do
you have to say to the charge that
people are saying that you're
actually way more than what the doctors
report I don't know about that okay but
I will tell you what I will tell you is
this okay Logan Paul everybody general
people shouldn't have been here okay mr.
president mr. president Babbitt but
today is by far the best budget days
online okay it's the best better for are
you wearing average merchandise right
now
absolutely I wear an underbite suit all
the time to protect me protect evil
spirits and watch evil spirits away and
also bad but that is what to a bad vibes
it frankly evil spirits including by the
way which nobody will talk about nobody
will talk about the fact that there are
witches goblins are you saying that you
believe in witchcraft major speech you
see what this did I'm going to be making
a major speech bury both witches instead
squadrons from entering the United
States is that really us is that so
that's all it but if things fun in the
nor goblins real absolutely not only are
goblins relay which battled and I saw a
goblin I was in the White House and I
looked at my okay I looked at my with
you I saw a couple nobody will believe
me I want to talk to you about the first
movement why are we talking about God
nobody this is classic tresor present
how tall are you always the flex well I
don't know I'll do this myself
okay this much what do you so every
white rach23
I don't know I'm at least a foot taller
than a cow but I'll tell you that much
right now alright mr. Prescott in the
sand here Ethan you can't let them dodge
around the question yeah I respect the
office I respect you immensely I hear
you about God
we're saying about guidelines in
witchcraft but there's a lot of people
out there a lot of charges against you
saying that you're actually obese and
that you changed your height so that you
said that you are not obese now are you
sure it's totally failing and that's why
you saying these things that's why
you've got carry the show is totally
fairly disgusting I regret that I had
watch by the way mr. president it's a
good watch by the way sponsor of the
program I just want to say nvm t he is
so good at that
like he really is a master class and he
are not answering questions dodge of
Goblin um some respect okay we handled
that really well yeah
all right and tough allegations sling
slinging Adam say what you will that is
your president okay no I were and you
will stand for the flag yes you will I
won't heal I'll never kneel and I regret
that I had to drop the president but
sometimes you just got to cut him off
yeah well he was getting a little off
he's still talking the calls been cut
off all right guys I've got a ton of
videos she just escaped from a [ __ ]
dungeon or she have no eggs no no no no
this is all good hearted fun he in order
pizza now let's talk about this order a
ton of pizzas for everyone on one of
these ten pizzas not ten but you could
I'd you and Dan make sure he doesn't go
crazy but get some pizza soon I say I
put together a ton of clips of the most
Awkward cringy clips from television
okay contest shows oh yeah so here this
one is [ __ ] pure gold my friends
Johnny from The Hague there's a show
called taking out in England or I think
it's England where there's like a
hundred women in the crowd and a guy
walks out and then they'll
anonymously say I'm interested in the
sky so have fun be like I want to [ __ ]
this guy right have fun with like I
don't want to [ __ ] this guy and
but you don't it's an anomaly so there's
no oh here so that's the premise here
Christ cheers by the way my friends yeah
cause I'll get in peach the Mall of the
second I don't think this is thinking I
just comment that they're not even
speaking English I don't I really just
hear your theory is calamari yeah yeah
close though they're speaking English
like spiritually that surprised all do
aren't we all you know it's all
beautifully played is the subtitle club
music so damn it I got one cell with
party on his shirt
god damn it and I listen if I don't you
gotta walk side you know guy walks out
with party undershirt you're telling me
that you're not sloppy walking wise
party that's some red pill talk I just
took a big ass for red pill might took
us we saw it was really weird one head
and one was yeah in applied the Vaseline
I meant to talk to you about that as far
the P is a you know you pay him right
hands gonna meet to me and five years my
boss maybe Vaseline his ass and apply a
foot wide with multivitamins I made you
decide something in tried to explain to
him the [ __ ] pills a metaphor yeah
come on take a fresh version - yeah to
point out that party shirt yeah I'm
Johnny 21 years old young oh wait I'm
sorry this is the dialogue support I'm
Johnny 21 years young cut him and I'm
from The Hague civilization The Hague is
that one of the wonders he's one he's
one of the wonders he's one of the ones
you know Johnny he's the hey make some
noise for Johnny do you know so he's on
a show where all these women are in
panels and they're gonna decide if they
want to [ __ ] him around
so makes a noise for Johnny from The
Hague Mister Rogers on the right
[Applause]
Johnny's the cheerful guy dresses very
basic and he says for sure I'm sure that
what is for shizzle in another language
makes you wonder right like what is the
yeah para shizzle fishes
although his appearance is very basic
you're all here to judge his appearance
so it's time to make your choice yes or
no take a couple seconds to think about
it and have your choice ready soon
oh god this is gonna go well bro
everybody ready everybody slam dressed
like immediately why so hard on him
guys why now earrings
can I say something party guy says yeah
yeah I'm so can I say something bro you
look like a lesbian TSA's no no I'm on
his side those girls don't know what
they're missing all right yeah he wears
on his sleeve that he likes to party and
these women are gonna pass that up
they're intimates they're absolutely had
that very ready thank you okay with that
I mean he knew he was gonna get rejected
looks like a dyke what is the word that
it's like a derogatory award for a
lesbian so he I mean he looks like the
biggest Dyke this is the body-shaming
episode of listen I would never make fun
of the guys appearance but he came out I
said you're all done he did say you look
like you look like the guys face on the
right
he's like he repeats what he said right
he's like they're all they're all dykes
yeah he buck
and he's like that I thought I mean I've
seen a Punisher is he sure this is very
familiar to me
I'm glad to know they have a Jersey
Shore in Italy too this is an Italy
they've got too much class for their
yeah check hungry all that good places
yeah I always plays Italians and sieve I
always built that beyond OHS forget
about it The Hague The Hague Hague about
it yeah I got a Google The Hague
that's gig what's in Dan and courthouse
right okay Google where is the Hague oh
I hate guessing shape what would you
have voted on I said I just want to say
this show looks horrible yeah it is what
is what it's not cringy it's horrible
five fine line laughs I [ __ ] line
yeah so that's a that's a genre of oh
yeah all right that explains the area I
don't want to go to the Hague this
weekend my Islander is open yeah where
it's famous for its famous for
International Court oh my god how did
you know that oh right it's just like oh
it's a court I picked that up somewhere
or is that what does it mean it's got a
bunch of facts a famous international
like a courthouse funny enough Dan says
they're famous for being civilized well
they'd fallen from grace this is beyond
Chris these are like morally depraved
game show right yeah they all said no
but he called them lesbians this reminds
me speaking of morally depraved game
shows there's it was either MTV or vh1
there's an old game show called next and
you know it sounds awful
yeah oh the bus yeah oh great I'll be
there like five guys or five girls in a
bus can I should I find clips there is a
clip of honest that is hilarious
is it the one where she next
he next all of them like boom boom boom
boom boom because that sounds amazing
oh yeah the one worthy like a chick just
immediately next a dude she's like next
TV it's either next next to me or
Dickies famous MTV next episode God well
I don't know like this epic there
there's but there's one where she like
chill net balls all of the next bus this
one's smart I like that yeah i xl yeah
again guys learn to like ratio that's
not great or not girl walks up always
judge the video by its like to dislike
ratio that's better
so yeah there's a camera on all the
people in the bus right so there's like
a guy outside waiting to see me for the
first time that's me so all five
contestants are behind then they come
out of the bus to like then there's like
a little like blurb like Melanie she's
21 loves to party lives here you know
like that kind of [ __ ] so she walks told
all of them she walks out meets him and
if he doesn't find her attractive he
next sir well like well to our face yeah
but like we can go on dates and [ __ ] but
he can say next at any given time it can
be immediate they can be later on in
mid-sentence he'll just be like let's
say she says something he doesn't like
he's like next and she has to go and the
next girl on the bus has to go like wow
enters it's the same flavor as that show
her where the all the people say notice
that's why I bring in the same pills
even more horrible because it's personal
thank you so much face I think I think
the one people with the buzzers is less
scripted perhaps this that's a really
good point central casting reality no
his line must have been they might have
given him the shirt like it's it's
completely logical for that guy to be
like I'm gonna wear this
putting these earrings and I'm just
gonna be it there from the beginning
introduced him as like look at he
doesn't dress well right a rack of
clothes no way that was real you guys
are too soon believe that that wasn't a
pure I mean we are pretty just an of
human depravity yeah I mean the [ __ ]
dude from The Apprentice just called us
so skimming over that the president had
called in and talked about goblet least
we forget that was a weird moment I
think God's really into got them know
well now that I'm red pill done more
than Vaseline please we have another red
pill please needs to be inserted I mean
if you paint that red was that novella
Longbottom it does look like him but
right so this is an English show called
your face your face of mine and so so
this is one of the worst I've seen so
the premise is yeah this guy has his
ex-girlfriend and a girlfriend and they
say to him who do you think is what just
to give you an idea smarter and then he
wins money based on how the audience
vote right so he has to be vote with
what he thinks the audience will choose
what commercial and heartbreaking things
that he sing to his right ones right so
they'll say the other girl your
ex-girlfriend is smarter really bad
might get a good oh my god drink more
just wrap it rubber band up jamming I've
been forgetting to do that too that's
much better air so the premise is that
he's gonna say horrible things about his
potential girlfriend - 1 money decide
with the audience here you're gonna see
that here good promise I'm intrigued
truly awful really off is this a Comedy
Central oh my god it is but this is an
English film there shit's all weird oh
that comic the hope the host I assume is
one-liners ever he's really good with me
I think he's on every show on BBC yeah
his name right he's doctor who first
name doctor yeah last name ever
first they dr. I was actually really
surprised to see him in this because
he's somewhat reputable guy in the
shadows just objectives garbage okay
yeah he read the one-liner on it was
like I'll do that Jimmy something right
yeah sibel yeah got him there was like a
moment of a few years of yeah yeah there
was like a window of time when this was
the norm and we all just kind of put up
with it well there isn't any but this
yeah I'm it's like be surprised how many
shows like that are still in the air
like it's kind of mutated a little bit
now it's in the form of like Real
Housewives Bravo network it's like
looking at a cyst grow and because they
have these stupid [ __ ] people into
these goddamn awful shows and then you
watch it cuz you're like this is awful
and you're like what am i doing oh
there's another one alright yeah there's
all them yelling at each other with the
[ __ ] ringleader himself now that
guy's name is Andy no god I hate it it's
a guilty pleasure you can turn it off
like there's this I have this one show I
want to show you guys called superstar
USA and this was a show in the 90s when
American Idol was at the peak of its
popularity and these Psychopaths said to
themselves let's make a show because
everybody loves the bad auditions so
they say let's make a show exactly what
you're picking all of the talented
people yes keep all the delusionally bad
people and vote through the worst person
about that man then at the end tell them
it was a giant prank and there actually
got him supplied with Eddie Murphy movie
right Norbit yeah don't forget keep that
in the back of your head if you don't
already have a cute in playlist I want
to say thanks I have that cued up
I have the finale of that show cute oh
that's that's what I want for now when
they break the heart unbelievable
unbelievable so we're building up there
people need to build up a resistance
before we get that yeah yeah yeah oh my
god it's awful your red pilling you're
with her audience come on I'd watch the
[ __ ] out of that
like any day cuz you know you know it's
like hey no we all have the bat out
audition exact listen respired American
Idol my first two weeks I've stopped was
it yeah I say man Oh Rubert stuttered oh
wow what do I hear what there's good
where there's already so much good music
what do I get right some pass give me
more William Hong's yeah yeah yeah give
me more of that William Hung man I
could've made a career oh just keep my
able to know the words an instant legend
in ten seconds okay I'm sorry we are so
far yeah your face they're mine yeah
it's still like texting don't mate
thanks nice I'll try a man about no I
think I've seen you actually in you've
got a white car yeah sometimes I see
people that I follow
[Music]
with Sarah let's say you were single now
why would you try it on again with her
of course if I'm single
unfortunately not just anyone don't get
excited
so kind you've won twelve little pounds
on the show so far if you get this right
we'll double your money your current
prettier yes always prettier hole I'm
gonna go Sarah no kiss Medina's heart
broke yeah buddy buddy buddy no no you
can't yes well you wouldn't like if the
audience votes with you one 2,400 pounds
I think he's just trying to guess what
the audience is called for he stands to
win 1,200 pounds is it worth it it'll
double yeah yeah hundred yeah man that's
like 0.5 bitcoins goddamn quit quit
bragging about your [ __ ]
cryptocurrency I'm into soul I got a red
pill I got red pill coins that Georgia
huge hand bitcoins and he was not
worried about how to change my money
into those beautiful okay so you're
saying Sarah for 1,200 pounds is
better-looking than your girlfriend well
let's see if the audience agreed god
Aubry oh this
[Music]
and they hide fine afterwards
what wait which was his girlfriend Lana
right yes the the black girl okay jesus
[ __ ] they had five gay made money
they high five but she's dead inside Oh
clearly yeah it's like I said earlier
it's like that Simpsons episode like
where you can pinpoint where the heart
breaks like that right that's awful
that's so but damn if it doesn't make
for good television
this guy would attach themselves so I'll
see him on reddit all the [ __ ] time
just like a one guy or like like how to
handle like comedian owns heckler and
it's like you know a nine minute montage
of him screaming at the audience I think
that guy gains power from the
destruction of human souls before that's
how that's what fuels said he saw this
show he was like just done I'll do it
for free I just said yeah snipe I don't
take money only suffering money so this
this is an American classic an American
classic
this is a staple the moment like Robert
Ross was a show that was seen this yeah
so they hook people up to lie detectors
oh and when they passed the lie detector
they get paid so it's like millionaire
except you just they ask you probably
worse questions on truly more yeah so
that's the premise okay the title of
this is a girl ruins her marriage on a
game show so I love it we're building up
my friends God get your tolerance high I
love cringe this episode was so
controversial that we needed to make an
announcement right promote it and market
we're coming at you at 240p I think
clearly that the 90s was all 240p
there's no you know looking at my older
videos I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] quality son
like your ears all via V never even
thought to save a higher quality version
of the nerdy question do you know what
you were shooting on back in those days
yeah it was just a TV cam it was a TV
cameras 480p
oh it's beautiful that was just a little
box you guys still get it
we still shoot movies like that like
good
just to shut me up please do leave the
doll you and then pin my comment when I
say to shake people be like why did you
do this
right all right to prove a point on a
podcast shot three months ago it's
starting to get to the point where if
you don't shoot an 8k people complain
that's very [ __ ] true died so M MK b
th okay yeah doesn't he shoot everything
in like 4k like he's gonna talk to kid
[Laughter]
no that guy is awesome he has like the
prettiest reviews honestly like when I
gave my Logan Paul when I saw that pink
hot ass maverick March - is that right
this guy deserves a second chance you
know I think it's always better to turn
pink into a style it takes a real man
can Paul go silent I'm pink build now
that's hot who's that what was that wait
go back
okay that's like some 90s book it's very
era like of the error oh wait this is
have you ever told a customer you like
their hairstyle when in fact you did to
a stray dog before oh my god this guy
did us a great service you really do
this right because otherwise this would
be an hour of padding answers right
that's pretty good Jordan I believe it
before you would give it to a homeless
person you feed it I'm kind of [ __ ]
question great question
would you that's kind of interesting
that's a lie to tell me we don't have
lie detector hooked up so we can say
whatever we're drunk that's true a
salute to a dog before homeless person I
which one do I see first buddy get some
you've got a sandwich you got a sandwich
it's dropped on the homeless guy take a
hit off my e-cigarette hey buddy hey I
got you yeah just be a man you're good
man good man and then you go it's
brilliant everyone's got one I know a
bug hunter is that one CJ is that real
going Craigslist I'll bet you this coin
into it that way hey I got bugs so
apparently there's like HIV parties were
guys who are infected go and take it up
the ass no that's not real
dude Brothers apps for gay aids dating
there's people who like cook their arms
off in [ __ ] like body dysmorphia that
doesn't make that makes sex I don't know
if that's real I did just say that
[Laughter]
because you already have it by the time
you got invited to one right eventually
as I understand it it's a little harder
to catch HIV than most people think
apparently if you're a guy it's almost
impossible to get HIV putting your dick
and stuff really yeah it's like you have
like less than 1% chance of catching HIV
putting your dick and stuff much higher
is when you're receiving mmm and but
most people get it from drug drug share
mmm the vast majority people get it from
needle sharing no because that's like
almost guaranteed no I always do a lot
of money on those parties oh yeah and
and and what did you achieve what you're
looking for no guys I'm healthy as a
clam and a maintenance hey switch users
is that is that a saying let us know in
the comments below but I think what the
thing about the bug chaser is that
because they know that they're so weird
and wild they think it's inevitable and
they just want to get ahead of it they
won't be like look I've got it ya know I
know I've got it and now I can rub my
dick with any didn't got to be like a
masochist
thing too you know like like delivering
pain to yourself in some way because
it's not just HIV that you're going for
like bug hunters I think I'm really
going outside my comfort level here with
the talk of the knowledge base is I just
know about the [ __ ] term because I
thought it was a funny name for it yeah
really
I'm a bug hunt I'd like to put on your
[ __ ] Crocodile Dundee here Danny and
can you guys do some research on you
they'd find me some bugs look on your
done net I need bugs and wonder what's
there look at the TV
TV's hot this month anyway with no
morality the questions are so devious I
think you can like super skip and just
go right to the middle have you ever
been fired from a job do you guys
remember the pier argh read the show
like the Fox gameshow greed it was like
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire but on
[ __ ] steroids and the prize was like
the tellurian it was like multi million
dollars but you could like vote off team
members and [ __ ] it's sorry that's what
I bring it is that's what I like
remember from this they're like yeah I'm
sorry it's up no no problem at all I'm
just pulling up this article on bug
chasing chasing sexual activity with
hiv-positive individuals in order to con
contract HIV individuals engage in this
activity I refer to as bugchasers it's a
form of self-harm good luck chasers seek
sexual partners for HIV positive for the
purpose of having unprotected sex and
becoming HIV positive gift givers are
HIV positive individuals who comply with
the bug chasers effort it's become
infected with HIV this is why Craigslist
got invented bro gift giver Craigslist
first post was gift giver here who wants
it by design bug chasing involves
unprotected sex but members of the
bareback subculture this is just full of
lies bareback subculture there's a clip
there's an article about bareback just
for anyone wondering
is it either like horse riding or simply
and now that subculture are not
necessarily bugchasers the differences
intent in reviewing the scarce
unpublished and published materials of
bug chasing as well as general health
care speculations and common appearance
the lumping of bug chases with bare
backers although these two groups share
some of the same practices namely
unprotected anal intercourse you and its
breviary
you AI there are distinctions that
differentiate bug chasing even though
all bug chases are indeed bareback this
is this is a meme right can I just say
for as long as I live on my deathbed I
will still have this memory ingrained in
my brain of of you pulling the window
into this video sailing oh I found an
article on bug chase this movie outbreak
the greater there's a sequel outbreak to
bugchasers yeah it could be like some
mumblecore [ __ ] like a bunch of are you
more of a gift giver or a bug chaser um
I'm in the middle between the two fluids
immediately the middle centipede
expecting that segue I listen I'm a bug
chaser for the antenna being a gift
giver it's nice to be in the hunt well
you can collect them like pokemons right
you know you got your bola there are
different types of HIV they're super
aids forget I'm gonna get hepatitis I've
been on the hunt for diabetes oh well
just the pizzas on the way
that'd be sex you could just go for a
bug yeah I don't believe that that's in
the know if you don't get that she's
like that and right now the pizza yeah
I'm trying to stay vegan
[Laughter]
right that's right like somebody who
doesn't speak English trying to say on
the kleiner Trump back on the phone so
no no God ing these bizzy's hire lawyers
let me do skip order on your
recommendation do you secretly stay in
touch many boyfriends that just make it
have you taken off your wedding ring to
appear as if you were single yes true
do you believe you might have been in
love with a former boyfriend on your
wedding day like why would you even ask
you guys to do you think this is
scripted kind of God say we have to warn
you this episode is so graphic right
it's completely stay away
is there a lie detector test in
existence that just spits out immediate
results like that or it's there
inadmissible in court yeah I was
watching an episode of minehunters
Vsauce for YouTube read series and they
have this [ __ ] machine that reads
your brainwaves based on recognition and
it's almost a hundred percent accurate
so like if you've seen the murder weapon
on a crime scene they show it to you and
you can't [ __ ] lie it knows it
registers your recognition brave
brainwave Wow no that was on Vsauce he
was doing something like that which one
crocodiles name oh the memories yeah it
was that one you know what black mirror
I like it but it's also like watch out
for tech my friends it's kind of like
repetitive
an optimist I see the [ __ ] we're like
you can put yourself into a [ __ ]
databank
and I'm like yeah yeah I want some Eric
in there I think Eric can do a databank
I well I'm gonna die my soul's gone
forever but like a little digital
version of me could live on I want to be
a gift giver in the data bank
there will be bug hunters looking for
you
they're like oh man that's powerful I
wish I could get HIV and just be like
well you know when we hit the
singularity god and have all the bugs
we're gonna share all the bugs is that
what you think will happen we oh mine
feeling so I think sorry I minefield you
700 different show it's all so good I'm
sorry I'm sorry no yeah I think Oni
Angie had a really good criticism of
Black Mirror and tweet the other day
when when he said like they're kind of
but like I love black mirror but they're
kind of recycling some of the same light
plot lines when it's you know it's all
like oh it's virtual reality like it's
like if you're gonna be an anthology
show if you're gonna be a modern-day
Twilight Zone which it is you have this
infinite world of strife hell yeah why
is it always got to be like dystopian
future by probably one of the best
episodes of any TV show of all time I
loved it say evil mastermind guy Jimmy
Simpson he is the main character Jamie
Simpson was the guy who's like kid he
had the lollipop always sunny yeah yeah
see mcpoyle on sunny and you're like oh
my god that's such a funny care it's
like a throws Westworld like oh he's
comedy what a gift different abilities
are just in like when he's hit his head
on the thing right right like that
there's no way that was in the script I
had to who's been Jimmy oh yeah de
living that's funny I don't know that's
a guess but no no I get incredible yeah
if you guys if you guys watch any
episode of black mirror make it season 4
episode 1 yeah the other are just like
oh my god you are honestly it showed it
like
should have been like the Ender for me
like that with these Netflix shows is a
different kind of thing like yeah I
think I think that there's gonna be like
a TED talk create content that comes out
all at once and how to stack it items as
if it's a weekly show then you can start
week and get stronger good and then the
final again like that questions way to
specific but let's go to like the
marriage rooming questions they brought
out her eyes is that British know I feel
like the editing I can't even tell
what's happening I feel like I'm in an
episode of memento yeah we're definitely
watching this woman's life before us
since you've been married have you ever
had sexual relations with someone other
than yours no stupid at least attempt to
lie Monsen deniability true i think that
they have to be out yeah it's just
because it makes for good television oh
yeah
after having watches i watched us a
while ago having watched it now i think
that this has to be big
well we also did just talk about a story
about that's finger by the way that was
made just for ratings to directors yeah
yeah it's all just made up for their own
crazy news balls
walls that's just way too perfect by
Mark Wahlberg it's missing the age so
it's not actually that's not Mark
Wahlberg Mark Breaux your name is
multiple Berg well the H is silent
yeah I'm Canadian Mark Wahlberg the last
question was do you think you're a good
person she said yes and then it's like
why really shit's fake yeah what's up
yeah yeah the lie detector is so not non
reliable like it doesn't mean anything
like uh like what is that [ __ ] mean
your heart rate spikes yes like that's
so stupid
I took an I when I was in Israel I had
to take a lie detector for a job
interview and I resented it it's so lame
yeah I I hate everything about it with
you when they're reading the result look
at you like yes even for a job interview
that's like not that serious to like
have you ever taken drugs which ones and
I'm just like I said no but I wish I was
just like none of your [ __ ] business
yeah well you go Neil now what was that
yes I'm sure it's like a psychological
thing were they like it's hard to it's
hard to resist getting anxious and
that's all that it what is it can like
put a pin or like a thumbtack in your
shoe mmm and like [ __ ] yourself up so
you can squeeze your [ __ ] actually is
the real test on you squeeze your
[ __ ] and it raises your blood
pressure and it completely
single-handedly makes the reading
completely unusual so every time you're
about to lie squeeze your [ __ ] I know
and I've been doing kegels ever since I
read that ass kegels okay I'm ready it's
the pizza here dance for chrissake jacks
were heading that down okay guys we
inside of the pros we have led to this
moment the most appraised super star USA
the grab
yes oh my god yeah there was yeah okay
so this is the worst this is real and
it's awful this is the one I was talking
about that's the bizarro birth right so
none of these people on say they can
sing but they think they can be as
they've advanced so far in this
competition exactly okay exactly right
all those there being fall right the
original just a prank bro that's right
superstar USA the suspense is building
because we're just seconds away from
announcing which one of these two
incredible oh by the way there's a twist
to this they recall they made a
documentary about this okay everyone in
the audience they couldn't tell them the
truth because people would feel so awful
they couldn't possibly cheered them on
so what they told the people in the
audience is that these are cancer
make-a-wish people and it's their last
wish to perform everything this is the
Nazi German Germany of television shows
it's like this shouldn't exist what
happened in the minds of these people
was a Fox show do you know it says it
was a WB WB I'm sorry yep there it is
Wow
and after this was Animaniacs [ __ ] up
the DC so even the audience wasn't in on
it
don't leave the superstar us look at
this guy man that's the poor son of a
[ __ ] is literally a dream come true
but they wish they really didn't do this
the moment has come out now The WB's
superstar USA is how did that guy not
win by the way it's the girl she went
started to bro the surprise which was a
girl got him timber to sing shot what is
low maybe they saw him doing it so
there's just going shot this is enough
later
maybe they saw trying to use my
imagination I think they saw doing it
and then they got the shot they're like
hey can you hang on can you go regular
hands again we're gonna pan down and get
that let's do things they shouldn't it
cuz it makes it look fake even if
they're like let's we see him acting
yeah yeah yeah what is that
let's just assume for now it's real
because it is real that's I'm I'm
already there baby it's real
Bosh ready today I'm sorry that you're
telling me that disappointment they're
not real err the [ __ ] do you know by
what they just told them to go back
right now go back bro this is real watch
her face
nobody she's good at math and that okay
I think anyway you should ensues it has
to do
[Music]
well it could still be okay I see it
yeah even cross your fingers don't look
like a learning - did you have any
doubts I think they actually get ten
thousand or something so it softens the
ball a little bit okay okay and a
lifetime of humiliation I think it was
like ten ten thousand I don't know it's
some mom and all mouth it's not like a
million bucks
there's charisma showmanship stage
presence sex appeal cut him and at least
Dustin other factors to take into
consideration and that's why you are our
superstar USA
out here this is missus chemical you've
been through a lot to get here but
before we officially crown you let's
take one last look at your long journey
to superstar to--let's oh [ __ ] balls
[Music]
[Applause]
some of the superstore USA you can with
thousands of audition week also
intervene Affairs to the perfect always
and this this was the only time they had
a live audience was the finale yeah we
found you Jamie pulled get a load of
this
[Music]
that actually wasn't that bad it wasn't
that bad though yeah it's chosen worse I
can continue to stay in this competition
we've wants you out of obscurity and for
you to Hollywood a fight for a chance at
fame and fortune reality because I mean
I'm here in Hollywood just feeling like
a star and when I get up on that stage
to thing I
when it came time to sing our other
superstar USA hopefuls didn't stand a
chance
sure myself so everybody else in the
competition better stay put by because
Jamie's here Jamie
the concert series whether it was true
[Music]
how's that sound check there yeah that's
my WB superstar get that w this is the
one that gets all the concern for is
silently watching indirect true villainy
well this one that's the difference yeah
this one's real I'm sorry can we express
can you press the J button on your on
the laptop so I can hear the beginning
of all by myself yes thank you so much
[Music]
the superstar
my god hit that note this makes me want
to buy the box set of the show but you
see it's compelling right it's like all
the best parts in American Idol
its gene is er like you all its mind by
show you're this it's they draw it out
they're tortured it's like it's sick bro
I just say the premises and meanwhile
the host is watching her like I do you
get it yet like it says do you
understand that this is a James Frank
but I yeah I mean just [ __ ] just
basically I don't know how she could I
figured I was shy I feel like he would
have taken it how are you gonna top this
guy well it did sells me cigarettes out
of a but but what if that guy just has a
voice of an angel
that's why he looks wise know that we
always think my WV superstore USA come
work just work he's problem he's
probably a Bitcoin billionaire so you
can shut the [ __ ] up dude bro this is
not a threat that's why I'm sure it'll
use toilet paper right the weirdest
thing
Oh God it's only downhill from here I'm
sure
[Music]
oh just [ __ ] just editor it's brutal
starts to get Lucy in her face she's
getting suspicious those weren't good
clicking it's silent you see she's not
even a lousy singing voice Oh
oh [ __ ] now they did this thing where
they try to soften the blow they go in
honor they go in on her and then they're
like but you're still a superstar our
hearts right everybody there's a twist
of the show you know you can tell by
your face she suspected this was coming
the whole time I just saw there's
[ __ ] five minutes left like do they
just berate her yeah and give her bugs
and then at the end of life but give her
a big round of applause
oh that's by the way this is the [ __ ]
let's give her a hand for America's best
singer
everybody give her the clap everyone
there's being like I really need to
reevaluate my life I wonder who that the
judges are like are they just like just
actors a little for a gig or yeah I mean
yeah I think they're probably comedians
right right or yeah I think they're
cancer patients who thought they were
America's best singer Oh nobody deserves
that
no [ __ ] Jamie we like I'm just
kidding you are a great singer
[Music]
the audience doesn't know they think
that she's a cancer this is the longest
violin string whatever unbelievable but
we didn't lie to you yeah so they
basically just [ __ ] on her in her open
mouth and made her swallow it and this
is how they this is how they make it
okay
that's um thank you yeah how do I react
he's in therapy to this day rumor so bad
but y'all think I got cancer so you're
clapping right now how how did you know
about the cancer twist I I it's kind of
foggy no I checked and it's also in that
Wikipedia page is it okay so I didn't
they were worried the live audience
members would not be able to
respectfully compose themselves during
the final performances so they deceived
the audience by falsely informing them
that the singers were all terminally ill
young people oh my god being a waste
fulfilled by it charitable organization
that is one of the most people Nazi
Germany happened because yeah you went
in there being like man good for you and
then at the end it's like no you suck
but then they're like the audience loves
you and they're like I don't know this
person yeah well I mean she's not gonna
live very long a very clap came out
right being in the in the shoes of the
audience like what is this right one
[ __ ] bite watching they're saying
everyone's cancer patient is a lousy
singer job was it to tell the entire
audience that everyone up on stage has
cancer all right so listen up everyone
listen up we know you're excited not a
good one what's my energy it has you be
what they did they basically yeah the
producer came out and just said
something like not
very clear he probably answer survivors
they're terminally ill this is a wash
last wish to be positive be encouraging
and cheer mom that's the best they could
come up with it worked
he said it was a prank on top of a prank
it was the only way to get it to work
they took their clever their iPad
themselves in the back when they really
thought about it I mean on paper like on
paper you know it can be like that's
pretty fun this was a pretty fun paper
yes an actual human execution is the
only show to do the old the old twist on
the take of reality because there's one
where it was supposed to be like The
Bachelor Joe Schmoe but yeah the guy was
not a millionaire at all he's just some
random that was a good show because the
winner to be like okay well this guy's
not a millionaire oh wait no no no I'm
sorry yeah that's one that's a great and
then there's another one where like I
think the Joe Schmo show was he thought
he [ __ ] what was it like he was the only
real actor and everyone else around him
or he was the only real person that was
Moshe and he like and they were also
like there are alliances and like you
know like immunity like and he thought
he had actual friendships with these
people very Truman showy extreme that's
all it was there was a Truman Show but
they may react to [ __ ] that's like one
and like once he won everyone comes out
and says like oh actually you know these
are help aid that was a little more
easier to it's still twisted but like I
think they can have fun with it they're
not telling anyone that people can't
take it he was all like he was very
surprised and shocked and didn't quite
get it and thought it was a little weird
but a camera should probably take it way
better than you actually take it yeah
because you know you're on
million bucks yeah meanwhile in your
mind you're like I'm definitely gonna
blow up a kindergarten that's it I'm
gonna get a wife we're gonna keep some
kids in the basement that's man that's
how it starts get myself one of those uh
motorcycle helmet haircut so go be the
end of my spawn all right and put my
spawn through hell oh I guess that's how
he talks now listen oh it's Riverside in
the effort into whatever it takes to
become a true superstar what are you
talking about I mean I think I'm weird
like what does that mean yeah the [ __ ]
does that mean the world was right to
present you with a $50,000 talent and
recording deal not a bad collection
that's it it's a $50,000 talent
recording deal everything's gonna cost
$49 all right you get two hours of
studio time no one to help you with
anything you got to run the board's
yourself right not far from the truth
such a good sport we're also being such
a good review another 50 in
[Applause]
chuck-e-cheese tokens so that hopefully
you don't
I think 50 grand but not for [ __ ]
unbelievable humiliation that lasts for
decades this was in the early 90s I
assume 50 K back then was early oh
really yeah find out America for TV look
like in the early nineties no weird like
up to here jeans yeah no no they would
have mom jeans this baby flared at the
bottom yeah there'd be more I'm checking
the halation flower petals on her shirt
that's true that was big I'm doing an
inflation emulator which was a 90 show
that's oh my god I know you boozled this
off sadly my friends fifty thousand
dollars back then is only 65 now I was
like well that's like a million so I
gotta invest cuz that [ __ ] goes [ __ ]
crazy
anybody any direct well I did it's my
refresh what big connect yeah briefly oh
yeah big connect have you guys seen that
I know but you had like over 400 code
they scampi's my it's not a scam use my
referral code no okay okay oh good nice
not be good one crypto is just a whole
[ __ ] weird wild ain't so funny I
don't touch that [ __ ] I don't like it
because I've started cornering people in
parties and and felling them to invest
in victims right I'm a service you're
just trying to help people you like a
Mormon trying to save a Jew soul my
favorite part of uh parties just
wondering yeah yeah we can talk about
this I slap people in the face I go you
don't understand
we're getting rid of the dollar it's all
horribly the dollar right it's not
connected to the centralized government
don't you realize that anyone could take
your dollars at any time and just run
with them I prefer just the Bitcoin I
prefer to have my coin
get lost with my computer unexpectedly
crashes right oh yeah all right listen
up what up
I'm done all right all right so just do
I do have one thing to say oh the judges
I just looked where musicians one of
them was a pop singer vitamin C yeah all
I know is that I want a dick in my ass
unwrap a bear back yeah I wouldn't eat a
bear back what's it full of though the
dick yeah
AIDS oh good like there's any question
yeah what are you talking about god I
just want to make sure obviously I want
to make sure we're on the same okay so
there are I guess vitamin C needed to
sell more records huh drink more orange
juice oh she had a sealing sex with
Dracula in that movie she [ __ ] really
yes [ __ ] now talk about getting vitamin
C sexy Dracula to flying around the room
with her it's crazy I was like that's
the chicken to the graduation song so
weird and then I watched it again and I
was like you imagine being a vampire
you've had so much unprotected sex over
the years you have so many you are
inventing s new STDs yeah vampires get
that cuz they're technically dead
already so they can't really get new
[ __ ] they probably carry around some
warts on their deck yeah they're like
man I've been alive for 2,000
here's this worse that will suck because
like by the end of being a vampire for
two thousand years you just be covered
in STDs right
you wouldn't look right you caught them
all that if I didn't have a real big or
four or five vampires but they don't
think about the real practicality and
you can't go to the doctor like Doc can
you burn off this work would you like
your vampire like in the oldest vampires
would have still gone through the 70s
hmm all right chlamydia up to the ears
totally like their ears would be that
pointy vampire thing you see when the
dicks have like mein the crystals almost
crying my favorite part in sex oh yeah
yeah it's how I gained power yeah we
need to write a parody vampire film
where they're just so scientifically
accurate Twilight Saga
exact Dracula 2000 an anatomically
correct
Twilight they're all they're all in like
iron lungs and just because they can't
die right it's like a fate worse than
death there's some like don't make it
worse than death to us to all horrible
suffering of chlamydia and then like and
Paul comes in and doesn't flog in front
of it go these [ __ ] not dead guys I
figured it out right they're not ahead
right right that's okay yeah yeah yeah a
mini bug on some what do you give give
him or Logan he doesn't have thing I
didn't have that you didn't have any
gifts Logan doesn't have to get have
many gifts Logan's apology tour though
that's where the [ __ ] is Logan or
Wyatt's or no up first of all why is
there no apology merch he is still no oh
that's a that's a great idea
he's still not made of IDEO kids I'm
sorry Logan pause I wanted to make an
apology that would really get out there
you know so I merchandise that like I
love talks
yes more like hey guys I really wanted
to do a puncture we gotta shave like
half that off my 32 years old man I'm
still less blank that's how your 18th
kids yeah it's 10 years younger
all right stress men I'm gonna slice all
right I'm gonna lay the [ __ ] down
because I drank too much honey as usual
but that's what the boys don't drink any
honey boy
continue drinking after this but I just
don't know about continuing to be live
as I continue to drink I think guys
leave this one the racial slurs on my
book the racial slurs I feel it's like
about to spill over I got a couple that
guy just from experience from last time
I'm like this is the time to cut it off
forever
so my friends thank you for joining us I
had a hoot a holler a blast a laugh and
out of total riot hope you guys had fun
too thank you so much did Jack or John
thank my name Jack guys please check out
his channel he's hilarious links in the
description thank you very common
etiquette hilarious link is in
description these wonderful two
gentlemen I love them please a round of
applause for these wonderful guys this
is always a pleasure yeah this is
honestly the best way to spend a Friday
afternoon god bless you thanks and Trump
for calling oh my god that was so
unexpected orden Jordan good kid sweet
kid he's a little mixed up he's got well
is he's like pretty rich from an 11 year
old very well-spoken for an 11 year olds
yeah yeah I really hope that we don't
get like keep kicking our doors in
tonight because if it's half a Bitcoin I
mean we're gonna die if I was his dad
I'd put him in a dungeon that that wrong
no no like like like well I think you
said it'd be like what's the private key
I think you said it but I think this is
something worth considering about this
whole dungeon thing what if the kids
were really shitty and deserved like
what up the kids were I'm going on
conspiracy right now to get ahead
all right did I go too far on that no we
just bug hunted us some controversy my
boy okay okay thank you guys see you on
Wednesday 7:00 p.m.
god bless you thanks for listening
thanks for watching enjoy the week and
enjoy the weekend thank you spending
your time with us have a super honey
don't smoke that's all I have okay guys
god bless you love you see you next time
Tata thanks for watching